way that protesters were treated was a
violation of the eating rice so we did
the report who did the research they
violated key human rights they tear gas
people when they can find people in
certain spaces and that gunpoint gave
them conflicting directions of which way
to go shot rubber bullets at turn
tasered pepper sprayed these are human
rights violations they shouldn't be
repeated people will in law enforcement
in Missouri don't seem to agree we're
hoping that maybe they'll listen if the
UN tells them that these are human
rights violations
no we think it's the first step in there
can't you know we can't bring my crown
back right we can make his life
meaningful by starting a movie I'm
hoping to see an indictment I want our
worries to be heard
you